what's up disney plus i'm randall park  and i play agent jimmy wu in marvel  studios wanda vision i'm kat dennings  and i play darcy lewis in marvel studios  wandavision now i want to talk to you  about something very important to me  we've all been there you're talking with  your friends or co-workers or your  family and you  let it slip you weren't thinking you  just got excited i stand here today to  represent all of these people in your  life and to ask you please please do not  spoil wanda vision remember when you  first realized that  was created  or maybe that scene where wanda uh  realizes that  the scene we're watching  for  stuff like that so  make sure to watch marvel studios one  division now streaming on disney plus  because we all want to live happily ever  after just like  [Music]